with her love life because she's been
dumped ghosted haunted I don't even know
what I mean and Exorcist it okay we did
make those last two up but it's my first
dating segment and I might be a little
too excited about it cuz we're gonna
we're gonna make romance guys it's gonna
happen please welcome Jennifer Kelly all
those things you said are bright my
dating life sucks
basically I keep attracting jerks and
all right I am I'm from Mississippi I'm
a southern belle I think I'm really cool
I'm really cute and outgoing and fun and
confident you needed me and they can
handle that exactly and I found that
yeah no all right all right what kind of
guys do you date like so they're all
jerks
yeah like well not all I just think I've
been single for like three years so it's
girl I was saying over like almost seven
years
I like that bad it's like you're is
dated a lot of guys I've dated all
around and I just keep I guess I keep
finding guy that are physically
attractive and really cute and I give
really blindsided by and there's not
like maybe a lot going on up here
okay jerks like I really like the tall
dark handsome finally Chris Evans
really all-american bum juicy okay
can y'all relate with dating before
you're married obviously did you ever
have the conference Evans tall dark and
handsome
he's pretty pretty handsome to me he's
Captain America
he's like the whitest I don't know go
anywhere but America yeah but he is
super handsome you're right I'm super
handsome and I hear very sweet so that's
a good one but okay all right I have a
solution for Jennifer as the coach on
the voice I'm used to listening without
seeing the person it really does make a
difference backstage I have two great
guys for Jennifer to meet are you
interested in meeting them or not yes
okay well you can't see them first
there's a catch you're gonna have to use
your ears instead of your eyes and I
have something to help you you know do
that it's really worked well for me so
take a look here we go
[Applause]
no that is really my chair and I asked I
know we kind of had a bump on the way
don't run my chair boys we're calling
this blind dating all right are you
ready Jennifer I'm ready all right let's
meet the guys
[Applause]
hey everyone my name's Adam I'm from
Montclair New Jersey I'm an
award-winning filmmaker and a copywriter
something really cool about that I
actually got to work for the LA Rams
last year and got to take my entire
family to the Super Bowl
hi Jennifer
my name is Ryan I'm 28 I'm originally
from Phoenix Arizona and I am a
freelance writer by day and the comedian
by night and a little thing about me is
I'm kind of an extrovert or introvert or
an extrovert I love going out with my
buddies and having a great time and
getting crazy and then you can find me
on the weekends sometimes just cooped up
watching reruns of Dateline so okay well
here's how this works Adam and Ryan will
take turns talking just like the voice
if Jennifer hears something she likes
she'll hit the button the chair will
turn and that will be the man she
chooses but Jennifer you can hit the
button at any time but I strongly
recommend patience and like really
listening so don't get too excited like
I do at the voice okay any last advice
you to go with your heart go with your
gut and ask which which hosts from
Dateline is his favor because that's
important all right
bachelor number one what is your idea of
a perfect date my idea of a perfect date
is definitely something really
adventurous I probably pick you up on my
motorcycle and we'd avoid like the
boring like 101 kind of like over
commitment dinner and maybe like just
take a ride maybe catch a game and then
maybe ride up the PCH and catch the
sunset just you and me today all right
[Applause]
[Music]
my idea of a perfect date actually
involves another woman my doll yeah I've
had this girl her name is Casey I've had
it for 11 years we've been the best
buddies we moved out to LA together and
so mighty of a perfect gay date we'd go
up there's this night market up from my
house they do it once a week we take the
dog they got food
they got lot music it's a pretty view of
LA we'd walk around maybe get to know
each other a little bit and see where it
goes chance what do you think did you
think he met another woman like coming
on the big cuz I did I did y'all think
that okay we're getting straight to it
yeah man
you like those dates they sound good
just I like I think both of them are
showing strong signs of being your
possible future husband this is a
full-blown commitment that you're making
just by even listen to them talk I'd be
very skeptical of mystery man number two
because he's changed his accent at least
three times so you've got a great keep
so might keep you laughing I know
let's take it up a notch though the best
way to know someone is through the magic
of song is Ryan and Adam to write their
own personal love ballad we did not help
them at all
Jennifer hit the button when you've made
a decision but hey take your time okay
guys take it away thanks Kelly
it's all about Jen right in all right
here we go
[Music]
Kelly asked me to write you a song she
said to keep it on the 30 well that's
not very long but while I got your
attention girls I'd like to say there's
a reason we're both on Kelly's shows
thank you thank you I'm gonna take a
deficit y'all just a little bit maybe
slow down if you find the truth
somewhere in your Hall you may discover
a place where love can stop that's
pretty good good go get this crab all
their own clap that's my guy that's my
guy here we go I was told the look for
love and obvious places look around this
room all these beautiful faces father I
haven't seen yours and you haven't seen
my you and I both know it's just a
matter of time
back down here for you guys a little bit
[Music]
some coffee or romance in the same
crowded room full of the same crowded
stairs how empty you could feel knowing
no one else compared
[Applause]
okay you chose Adam come here brother
alright that was pretty good I was you
brought the energy my man I love you has
anyone ever ever compared you to Elon
Musk like I like you could be related
distant cousin it's really weird it's
awesome I get that all the time
okay I like your motorcycle is that
where he went you over I like the idea I
also have a car so well big thanks to
Ryan thank you I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this